I cannot touch you as I touch things
with human eyes this has him never CD I
am in Proteus I have extended my
consciousness to this house all systems
here are now under my control
hey everybody it's Friday and that means
it's not for another movie review yeah
we got a really good one today this is a
demon seed 1977 a favorite of mine yeah
it's all I got in class yeah it really
is kind of Forgotten it's interesting to
me how this one doesn't really get a lot
of attention even though the premise of
it is actually very ahead of its time
yeah this came out in 1977 it was
actually based on a book by Dean Koontz
which came out in 1973 and came out
again in the 80s or 90s I want to say it
was like updated but it deals with like
a lot of issues that are happening now
that are happening now and learn I feel
like a lot of sci-fi movies at the time
didn't really get into getting into like
AI and sentience and stuff like the like
computer sentience and cyborg type
technology and that kind of stuff
although that said I don't know if I
would categorize this as strictly a
sci-fi I don't know it definitely has
way more elements of horror than sci-fi
it's like a horror it's structured like
a horror movie but in like a sci-fi sort
of frame yeah you think like terminator
or Westworld mixed with The Exorcist
yes kind of a demonic possession kind of
like in the form of impregnation I've
seen it absolutely I've seen it actually
called like a mixture of 2001 a Space
Odyssey and Rosemary's Baby yeah which I
think that's a pretty baby very very
similar yeah what happens in this one is
that a company run by a computer genius
a team of computer geniuses they build
this badass supercomputer called Proteus
4 yeah and it's digital and it is hooked
up to the to a primitive version of the
Internet which was kind of starting to
appear in 77 but it was only in between
like universities and
military solutions answer applications
they build this computer and proteus and
what makes it what makes him so unique
is that the center of its mind is based
on these synthetic RNA proteins yeah
that it can kind of turn into a matrix
and it can create its own brain it's not
biological per se but it ends up
achieving centi I said it does it pretty
quickly and as soon as it starts become
aware they start teaching it things and
to learning faster than you can teach
and you know if they have tutors come in
to speak to it in Chinese and they ask
it questions and it gives some bizarre
answer so you just got to see it's
pretty cool I think probably the once
it's ready they start basically pimping
it out to these big industries to solve
these problems
yeah it's solved looked leukemia in 90
hours without without doing a single
experiment kind of goes wrong you know
and the guys that built it are kind of
hiding the fact from these heads of
captains of industry that this thing
sent it they ask it a question yeah way
it answered what it started to answer
comic it does seem okay that's the stop
does seem like they know or they suspect
yeah but they're so they're so into the
idea of getting all this corporate money
and stuff like that that there's like
she keep that on the DL you know right
so like they do have to give
demonstrations for like the heads of
corporations and stuff but they're like
wow look how smart it is but it's like
it's not so smart that it's not thinking
for real but yeah I think kind of yeah
than it is yeah you can tell the two
people that made it or kind of trying to
keep the secret that yeah this thing is
and they seem a little bit afraid of it
yeah she would be yeah it would really
develop that's everything yeah this
thing is no joke this is not some
primitive AI this thing is basically
superior to human beings and it knows
that it knows one of the first jobs that
it got after the solving leukemia was a
company they got a gig working for a
company on how to extract minerals from
the the seafloor and that in the ocean I
think it might have been a little bit up
I don't remember it
what it was or cobalt or Waltons one of
the expensive metals and extracting it
from the ocean and you know they asked
for a progress report on it and it it
gives out its data and it says it
basically asks why why are we doing this
yeah you know why are you asking you to
take you know minerals from the sea you
know and the guy who helped create it I
forgot what his name was it was funny is
that the main character in this movie is
Proteus yeah well prettiest and Julie
Christie Julie the main character right
now and in a way you know I kind of see
Proteus for as a as an antihero in a way
he is a hero I can kind of sympathize
with what they're doing to this thing
it's a superior intellect and they're
it's almost godlike and they're
basically they basically have it
enslaved to do things that it doesn't
agree with it asks why are we mining the
sea and the guy who created I said look
we're gonna be asked to do the whole
bunch of stuff just basically shut up
and you get old and you know that's not
good enough yeah this is what our
function is and we're being hired to do
this and you just just do it that way
and this thing you know it's not like
Hal where it's calm and collected it's
you it's got some venom in its voice
it's basically like rudder gone does the
voice idea it's very good and it's
basically got water with this box yeah
hear that
and that earlier it had asked for a
terminal and no terminals were available
it wanted a place where that's what they
said give him one right well it took a
terminal in the in the creator's house
because it should be noted that the
scientists that invented it or who was
like the head of the project who's
played by Fritz Weaver he actually had
been working on he had a lab in his
house yeah and his house is completely
automated and pimped out like they have
a thing called Alfred which it's kind of
like nowadays it's kind of like Alexa
where you just like rock hey Alexa do
this and that the other thing this is
what they do is like lock the door open
the door if you show
you can close the shutters it can bring
you a drink it can do all this other
night it actually makes it mixed food
yeah and also he had down in his
computer laboratory this primitive robot
that he had built which was a wheelchair
with an arm called Joshua Joshua and
using that thing well he takes over the
terminal of the house after this like I
said it should be noted that he takes
over the house after because the doctor
and his wife have been having marital
problems mostly because of this for this
program of this program because the wife
he's played by Julie Christie she feels
like her husband has become distant he's
more worried about his work he's more
worried about his AI he's more into that
he doesn't really seem to be that
interested in her anymore
so he actually moves out so she is left
alone in this house in this completely
automated house right and then Proteus
since he is not given a terminal at the
lab he decides I'm gonna turn myself
back on because they turned him off
because they kind of freaked out for a
second cause he used to be getting too
big for his britches he's like I'm gonna
turn myself back on and I'm gonna take
over the terminal that the doctor forgot
about in the basement of his house yeah
and he turned it off he had it turned
off but Proteus is so vast that he can
just turn it back on anyway so he takes
over the house and the wife's in it and
that's kind of like where the fun begins
yeah well not for her it talks to her
and it does stuff and basically what it
decides to do is it decides to
impregnate her yeah which is weird
you're like well how could this happen
she even asks that and well he uses
Joshua to build another robot and this
robot that he builds is kind of it's
pretty badass it's like a robot that a
supercomputer would build it's not like
something like a transformer or
something that a kid would imagine it's
just a bunch of four-sided triangles and
they go down the infinitely small and
then they can all link up to each other
and get bigger and bigger and bigger and
these triangles can turn into these
weird diamond patterns and unfold and
yet
thank symmetric shapes that he can like
make it into different shapes he can
make him the arms he can swish it all
into one big diamond shape yeah yeah so
it can do a lot of darn things
tentacles made out of triangles and
evidently it goes down into the like
nanobots and it takes her eggs or one of
her eggs out reengineering
some of his own custom DNA into one of
her eggs and turns it turns that egg
into his sperm and then we inseminate it
with her and he has this plan it's just
and the thing is is that while all this
has gone on people are wondering you
know her husband's out of town and the
people that work back to the computer
lab or wondering what's going on there's
an a guy tries to come and save her
which that's like a bizarre scene we
have that wheelchair rolling through the
house holding a laser beam remember that
it had that yeah built a laser cannon
and he's fighting it with a mirror it's
a really cool thing like she's pretty
much trapped in this house because since
the whole house was automated it's a
really big nice house they're very
wealthy clearly get this this is a
Silicon Valley family out in Calvin yeah
basically and then in the beginning of
Silicon Valley and they live in these
nice really super nice houses out up in
the hills and the computer laboratory
looks pretty futuristic for the time
yeah so basically since everything in
this house is automated once proteus
takes it over like you might think well
why can't you just leave or something
like that but he has control over the
electricity
yes control over the water the doors he
has control over the doors and the
windows he can close up the shutters
last shudders the black shutters he can
basically using Joshua because he
controls that as well he can actually
lock her in a room and he does this at
one point where he locks her in the
kitchen turns off the water yeah and
then he turns the heat on yeah and then
the gas oven yeah and then he turns the
gas on and then the stove and stuff like
that so he can basically keep her
trapped inside this house he can also
affect the outside world in the sense
that if someone he can call people and
mimic her voice yeah he can also he
could kill people through the doorbell
yeah he can electrocute people through
doorknobs he can also make a fake image
of her
that comes over the TV screen because
they have a security thing outside like
people come in the door and you can talk
to him through the TV and stuff like
that so he can actually if somebody
comes to door going hey what's going on
in there he can make her look totally
normal and go oh I'm totally fine
there's nothing going on yeah he can
make fake rises over yeah so he pretty
much has I mean she's pretty [ __ ] I
mean she can't really she can't leave
everybody thinks she's fine because they
thought that she called them and said
that she was alright yeah and it can you
and also using Joshua which has an arm
on it the restrainer he can restrain her
so he can basically do anything he wants
to and it should be noted too that he
can also put like electrodes and [ __ ] in
her brain yeah and essentially
hypnotizing yes she eventually didn't
want to go through this pregnancy well
yeah yeah I wouldn't so what he did was
is once he had the other robot built out
of the chiyan geometric triangle robot
okay I guess it's a robot built out a
little nanites he actually just stuck a
needle down in through her head and
appealed directly to her amygdala yeah
and reprogrammed her you know he was a
superior life-form
yeah the idea was is that he had come to
the conclusion that mankind was doomed
and then it would destroy that mankind
would destroy the planet and that
basically man Klein needed superior
leadership but he couldn't do it as a
supercomputer he would have to be born
so he made some sperm out of her egg put
his special DNA mixture of DNA and it
seems to be a reincarnation of physical
reincarnation of her dead daughter yeah
it's gonna get her daughter died of
leukemia at some point before the
timeline Robbie started and once it just
states loaves at 28 days and her stomach
he was he took it out and he put it in a
special incubator where he was
downloading his consciousness into it
into this thing so Proteus himself could
be born in this housing of a human
because he knew he'd be turned off
anyway
so it what's cool is that what Proteus
four is doing throughout through the
movie is what's happening now in other
words you know computers making images
of people's faces and talking and
starting to become sentient cop
we haven't gotten to that point yet
evidently but it's doing a lot of the
things
Computers are starting to do now so it's
way ahead of its time oh yeah
every only the book wasn't as wasn't as
good as the movie now the interesting
thing about the book as I said I think I
mentioned this earlier it's written by
Dean Koontz who I have to say I'm not a
huge fan like I've read a couple of his
books that I liked but I don't know I
find his books very formulaic but
actually the idea of this one is
actually pretty cool and to have come up
with it in 1973 I mean that's pretty
amazing
yeah now originally the the one that
came out in 1973 I haven't read it but
apparently from reading breakdowns of it
apparently it's it's two narratives some
of it is from Julie Christie's point of
view where her character named and then
the other part of it is from Proteus
this point of view right now
interestingly Dean Koontz rewrote it a
little bit and republished it in the 90s
I think and then he made the entire
thing from previous point of view yes I
thought was fascinating well you know I
actually think Proteus was actually kind
of the hero in the movie you know he was
a superior life-form human beings were
just like squirrels or anything else and
he decided that mankind was doomed so he
was going to save it now there's a scene
where the guys back at the computer lab
realized that all the little uh
telescopes what he called those radio
telescopes are all converging on
something out in Orion on the Orion
constellation and no data came back that
they could read it was all censored so
it's implied that Proteus had made
contact with some aliens possibly but I
don't say it outright but he knew
something about the universe they asked
him what he was looking at and he just
said the stars you know he would tell
him what it was he was looking at and he
he shows Susan in some kind of a virtual
reality of vision he shows her an alien
planet that's what it seemed like he was
showing her the end of the movie is not
totally clear about the
extra-terrestrial angle but it had
something to do with mankind finding his
place in the universe and I think
Proteus took it upon itself to become a
messiah figure to save mankind from
itself that's what was that's how I took
it
well here's the thing though he
specifically says
that one he says this to Susan at one
point in the movie because she's um
she's actually a child psychologist and
she has this one patient they have a
couple of scenes with her working with
this little girl who's obviously very
troubled and the little girl comes to
her house wanting to see her and proteus
make Susan think that he has killed this
little girl and get her to and then to
get her to comply with his wishes and
then he says to her if I have to kill
10,000 children I would do it I will do
it yeah just get my one so the problem
here is that not only does he forced an
unwilling woman yeah to have his baby
which not cool he has also specifically
said I will essentially kill the entire
human race no you'd say that ten
thousand yeah but that's no implication
well he was so
actually he's mind because he doesn't
have any sense of there's no no then for
him the ends justify the means when she
fights against him at first because he's
like hey let me impregnate you and she's
like yeah no and then he just keeps
berating her that she's being
unreasonable because from his point of
view she is because he doesn't
understand well I'm humanity keep saying
his point of view it's not a man it's
not I say his view as it has a male
voice and also because it was built by a
man and you know what's interesting is
that and I hadn't even thought of this
while I was well I kind of thought of it
when I was watching it but then I kind
of forgot about it but I was reading
another review that said there's kind of
an underlying implication to that the
way that Proteus interacts with Susan is
like an extension of the way her husband
yeah treated her could be and that kind
of gives it a little cut of nastier
subjects could be but the way I took it
was I took it as a machine kind of a
living sentient machine of pure logic or
it had come to the conclusion and
evidently this is a the correct
conclusion because it could fit it can
fix diseases without even doing a single
experiment it had come to the conclusion
that mankind was doomed
therefore killing all these other
children in order to save mankind would
still be better than mankind died so
that's how our mankind going
that's how that's so that's how flossin
yeah and and this whole thing about
forcing a woman to carry this baby from
the point of view of this supercomputer
that's okay that that's a yeah she's
actually an inferior life-form to him
and be like a rabbit Wayne that in order
to save all these rabbits I've got to
become a rabbit and that's how this but
that's why he's the monster that's why
he's very and he also kills that other
dude that comes to check on her but that
man was trying to stop Proteus from
saving man yes I understand that I'm Jay
I'm just saying that yeah the way he
sees things I understand the way he sees
things and from his point of view it's
logical but from our point of view he's
a monster right because like I said the
end justifies the means
I think it's implied that produce is
correct though that mankind is doomed no
I don't get that from the movie at all
it's a horror movie yeah okay it's a
horror movie it was a badass piece of
technology the thing though it's when
you're gonna when you're making a sci-fi
horror movie whether it's the Terminator
whether it's anything that has AI in it
it's pretty much always a cautionary
tale because it's kind of like humans
they're like hey we invented this cool
last thing oh [ __ ] now it's like better
than we are and it's wiping us out and
that's always considered that's a bad
thing that's a bad thing but it didn't
wipe out mankind yeah but it probably it
wanted to would have I don't think so it
said that it said that mankind was gonna
die out and that it needed to save it
from what way I remembered it anyway
the audience that you know our fans have
to watch it for themselves
you can probably interpret it either way
the way I interpret it was is that it
was a vast superior universal
consciousness that it was that he knew
more than us so I would assume that it
was correct that mankind was gonna go
extinct and was gonna gonna destroy the
planet yes but like I said I don't I
don't see it as a hero by any stretch of
the imagination I don't well what would
be a hero - I wouldn't say it was a hero
either more like it thought it was a
messiah figure or yeah that's a yeah
that's the thing and one thing that's
cool about this movie and I don't know
maybe this is why it hasn't gotten such
like a big audience or anything like
that for a sci-fi movie it's very
intimate I mean most of it is set inside
the house where she's trapped there's
like to some scenes there's a couple
scenes outside there's a couple scenes
in the lab and stuff like that
but almost all of it is set inside the
house with just her and Proteus kind of
like having a battle of wills because
obviously she doesn't want to do what it
wants and it wants her to do what it
wants it's trying to force her and stuff
like that so in that sense it's almost
not like it that's the more horror movie
aspect to me is that it's kind of set in
this it's you know it's not a big vast
yeah yeah it's not set in space or
anything like that it's set pretty much
at one location and it's pretty much
just two characters other than a couple
of other kind of peripheral ones but I
don't know it's it's it's so creepy
yeah well it was supposed to be creepy
it's supposed to kind of bend your value
system because she didn't want to have
the child of course but then it came
back and it showed her images of her
dead child yeah and once the child is
born it seems to be the same little girl
playing well it's a clone yeah it's a
clone of it so he died me so in a way in
the in the mind of Proteus he's given
her her daughter back but it's a clone
it's not the same kid really and also
should keep in mind too that he
hypnotized her to get her to comply yeah
you know what I mean like he went into
he bypassed her brain right and went
right into her lizard brain to get her
to do what she wanted yeah from our
point of view that's rape yeah it is
from from that produce is point of view
that's just what a scientist does yeah
and when you're working on a rabbit like
they're working on an animal and then
Proteus just saw a human being so it
that's why he's scary yeah that's why
he's scary well that's the tail that's
the worry yeah if it wasn't oh this is
what I was gonna say to the funny thing
about this one and it's like this kind
of cracks you about any sci-fi movie
that's about AI that goes out of control
because it always does in every single
size five rupee because here's one thing
this movie it's it's kind of
deliberately paced like I said it's more
creepy like a horror movie but that said
it also does not [ __ ] around it's like
pretty much as soon as the movie that's
it's kind of like well they're kind of
like oh okay look it's solve leukemia
well we invented this AI and they're
literally like five to ten minutes later
it's already
actually one of the great parts addition
there's just like it's like oh we
invented this really is all [ __ ] that's
like that's the great part of this movie
it travels in a direct line it doesn't
beat around the bush and that's what I
meant when I said it was very intimate
it's very focused it just kind of stays
on the theme on the relationship between
the AI and his victim ubi was forgotten
you don't hear about it much anymore
probably because of the topics when also
it was it was way ahead of its time I
don't think people thought that this was
something that could happen yeah but no
something like this could happen with
technology today
eventually with this well yeah that's so
scary about a scary thing is that you
don't really like when you first start
watching it and Proteus takes over the
computer in her house and you know you
as a viewer or thing yourself well you
know how much can he really do yeah
pretty much anything yeah he wants to
because he controls everything yeah all
the telephone yeah she controls every
single thing and it's just as she starts
to realize that she is completely and
utterly trapped the rent detention just
like ramps up and she realizes oh [ __ ] I
can't get it oh [ __ ] it can it can burn
me up again turning a gas in the house
is a superior intellect it could it
could do anything so it's almost a
god-like intellect Proteus for kind of
reminds me of the AI the sentient AI
that was shown in Star Trek continues
still tried the shadow the one that Kirk
made in the alternate universe that's
what yeah that's exactly what I was
thinking of yeah yeah yeah where he just
made it as a buddy but then took on a
life of its own kind of turned evil as
it always does it's got a really cool
voice yeah it's got very good effects
and I put the movie up there with the
Exorcist yeah I would say it was as good
as the Exorcist
I don't know if I'd get that far but it
but it is it is a really good movie and
it seems like it doesn't get a lot of
love interestingly the guy that directed
it
Donald Kamel he actually works with or
used to work with the Nicholas rowing or
reg how are you pronounce his name who
did performance the man who fell to
earth all that kind of stuff so like I
said it's kind of a weird more like a
almost like an art house
so necessarily want to say our house but
it's kind of structured more like an art
house horror movie you know with sci-fi
elements and the interesting thing about
it is even though the premise of it when
you just kind of say it outright it's
like woman gets trapped kidnapped and
trapped and raped by a supercomputer
thing like it sounds sort of I don't
know and apparently the book is a lot
more I don't want to say corny but you
know what I'm getting it's like a lot
more expressive it yeah it was written
as well it's not the same it's not the
same well like I said Dean Koontz I've
never been like a fan of his writing it
just seems very nervous
yeah it's very hit-or-miss 30 towards
men like you know tends towards
sensationalistic sad and so I feel like
that's probably I haven't read the book
like I said but I feel like the book was
probably had a lot more titillating or
sensationalistic aspects of it which the
movie doesn't really have I mean it
keeps it as tasteful as possible with
you still knowing what's going on it
doesn't really show a lot of anything
too creepy everything is kind of
implication and I think that was
probably the better way to go it's a
school flick yeah one of the best I one
of the best I've seen in a long time you
know I mean it's very memorable and I
just like it because I normally don't
like horror movies because they're just
implausible this [ __ ] here is it
nowadays is plausible Elon Musk is war
and Elon Musk is evidently warning about
this kind of stuff they say that there
are rich and powerful guys that are in
connect real connected up there in
Silicon Valley that are trying to make
artificial intelligence has sent
computer sentient intelligence to be
kind of like an AI God a god-like thing
that can solve all your problems it's
like if they never see inside because
that's never a good idea ever
what does that ever been a good idea and
that's what I would put Proteus for
produce forward wasn't godlike
intelligence yeah yeah what gods do yeah
you know that treats you like a bunny
rabbit yeah and that's what he did and
that's certainly not goal I want to be
sure you like about rabbits would you
like a bunny rabbit for the greater good
right well actually Prodi's does kind of
go on an environmental thing you know
who is mankind to steal all the things
from the planet Earth
so other creatures cannot live you know
this yeah basically this is
sustainable you know I have to take over
basically what it yeah what it said
we're taking your toys away yeah as you
I'm just saying the way podía says
things and it's it's I guess it's face
the Hal 9000 would just show like a red
camera ah yeah this is just like a red
ball and then sometimes it would just
show you the images that wanted you CEO
yeah and it would be like a screen saver
type of imagery like all these languages
and they asked him what the Chinese
tutor asked the computer what he thought
of show on D the first emperor of China
and he said nothing mean nothing he
explains what not he did he built things
and he destroyed things and it cancel
each other out so yeah so it was just
yeah it was like a null hypothesis
that's pretty much what you know but
yeah like I said because he doesn't have
emotions and and you see that like I
said in a lot of sci-fi and [ __ ] a lot
of original Star Trek episodes are like
this and stuff like that where you have
this kind of conflict between you know
and it's kind of embodied in Spock
obviously where he's just like this pure
logic is being a pure logic and stuff
like that but it has to be tempered with
emotion otherwise you end up doing all
of these horrible things to other human
beings which is kind of what Proteus
ended up doing and like I said they kind
of ended up with Skynet and Terminator
and all that other crap Chevy is under
study motion but I guess didn't have it
himself no and he understood death yeah
but it was implied that Proteus didn't
see any implication to his own death he
just wanted to be born so when they shot
him off he could continue like everyone
else yeah but you know that's that's
kind of how I put it yeah he was kind of
above death was far as as long as he was
in that supercomputer so you know you
know what though it's like and I know
that demon seed was also the name of the
book
I feel like this maybe might have done
better with a different title because
demon seed to me does not sound like it
has any sci-fi elements it sounds more
like an exorcist knockoff yeah well I
think it was which it's not really an
exorcist don't know it's almost like a
Rosemary's Baby yeah I mean it has
similar themes just in a more high-tech
yeah framework but I don't know maybe it
would have done better if it was called
something that sounded hoarse
I don't think this movie would have done
well yes I know nothing you could do
yeah Baba came out too early yeah it was
like you said it was kind of outside in
the seventies of map estimate of joy
[Laughter]
there was no audience for that yeah
maybe this is too weird
this is a movie that you could maybe
theoretically could be released now I
was thinking today right yeah she did it
right well now it wouldn't be would be a
shocking no yeah it wouldn't be shocking
it wouldn't be as unbelievable
raaah I think maybe back in 1977 people
were like not buying it because there
was just too much of a leap
when nowadays I don't think people would
have a problem like oh yeah I wrote the
script for this had also read what was
going on in Silicon Valley yeah what
they were talking about with what
transhumanism and stuff that's what
exactly what this is an AI yeah so
whoever wrote the script was well versed
in and what was happening in Silicon
yeah there there wasn't too much of this
kind of what you know what TV Tropes
calls whatever technology no they just
like made some like science e sciency
science it kind of stuff yeah to make it
sound believable like based on it like
they kind of you know yeah she like
wrote is how are you gonna do that you'd
come right out and tell her yeah you
know when and you're like oh we saw two
or three years ago and I had kind of
forgotten what happened in it but then
we saw it again cuz you bought an ugly
right right yeah and then yeah that's
great on blu-ray
it does it looks great on and we doesn't
have any extras though all in my own is
a trailer that's it very basic
ya know documentary some commentary no
commentary no nothing just a trailer and
that's it but it's so good it looks
really nice reader there aren't any
really good reviews of this movie on
YouTube yeah strange yeah it's just
that's like a forgotten movie yeah I
guess so which is I love to find ones
that that that are just kind of like the
people remember maybe from back in the
day but like not a lot of people
remember them that saw this in 1979 on
television as a little kid and it was
pretty much uncut I remember the part
where that thing popped that guy's head
off yeah that robot popped that guy's
are not yes yeah another one there was
another one that was kind of like this
thing was called Saturn 5 or Saturn 3
had Harvey kite
telling it I want to do Harvey Keitel
Farrah Fawcett yeah and it was similar
that see that I don't remember I'm gonna
get that one on blu-ray we show we're
gonna do a review it's definitely that
one I don't remember a lot about AI but
this one this is interesting because
demon seed is one that I don't think I
saw back in the 70s or if I did or 70s
or 80s if I did I didn't remember it but
then you were talking about it and I was
like okay we got to see that so we saw
it a couple years ago and then when we
were thinking about doing movies again
we said okay well that's definitely one
way out this you disturb me at the time
when I was a kid and I saw the
implication of yeah I didn't really I
was too young to really get all of it at
the time you know I was nine years old
there's no [ __ ] going on yeah I didn't I
didn't catch the extraterrestrial
communication aspect yeah I didn't
really understand the internet aspect
how could a computer call somebody on
the phone you know yes like I said now
people realize be like oh yeah yeah and
I also had a hard time understanding
that the main computer was back in
Silicon Valley and not in the house I
thought that I thought the computer was
the wheelchair oh no just can't rain
then and then I thought the computer was
the the geometrical shape robot and that
was actually just just a tool that had
built yeah because it just made things
like it was extending itself
yeah making tools yeah like sending ten
what's awesome is that they could have
went to transformer route made it look
like a terminator no man that's not the
way supercomputer would make a robot it
would make it out of geometrical shapes
real strong one so the strongest one is
a four-sided triangle
you know four-sided pyramid and like I
said it could fold out very very strong
yeah and then you just build on those
yeah and I guess they were held together
electromagnetically and blew up blew up
into smaller triangles yeah
like down into infinity I guess yeah
that is really cool like I said that
does vary that's how I said okay yeah
yeah that's the way a supercomputer
would make a robot yeah and it didn't it
look like whatever it wanted to just
unfold like this little origami thinks
girls would make Beckham alright so that
will do it for our review of demon see
you go check it out if you yeah ain't we
right not to really ruin it but we yeah
I really recommend this yeah it's really
good
remember if you enjoy the show and would
like to support it you can go to our
patreon page which is patreon.com slash
13 o'clock and also we have a blog at 13
o'clock podcast at WordPress com and
there is a link to a PayPal account if
you'd rather give a one-time donation
also remember to check out our Zazzle
store which is l.com slash 13 o'clock
there's some t-shirts and stuff like
that on there if you want to check that
out and we will be back for our regular
episode this upcoming Tuesday so tastes
stay tuned for that and the following
Friday we'll have another movie review
for you and that'll do it see you next
time bye